OK. So a man sits in front of a camera in his own home, trying to somehow summarize who he is, all that had happened to him over 14 years.
好的。所以一个男人坐在自己家中摄像机前，试图以某种方式总结他是谁，以及过去14年里发生在他身上的一切。
Hi, everyone. My name is Mohamedou Ould Slahi. I'm from Mauritania.
大家好。我叫穆罕默杜·乌尔德·斯拉希。我来自毛里塔尼亚。
It's hard, right? Like, do people even know where Mauritania is? He tries another take.
这很难，对吧？人们甚至知道毛里塔尼亚在哪里吗？他试着重录了一遍。
I am from Mauritania. In case you don't know what Mauritania is, which is very likely, it's in West Africa.
我来自毛里塔尼亚。如果你不知道毛里塔尼亚是什么——这很有可能——它位于西非。
And he continues at length. Doesn't work.
他继续长篇大论。行不通。
This is too long. Too preachy. Another take. Hi, everyone. Peace be with you. My name is Mohamedou Ould Slahi. I was kidnapped in 2001, and spent more than 14 years, mostly in Guantanamo Bay.
这太长了。太说教了。再录一遍。大家好。愿和平与你们同在。我叫穆罕默杜·乌尔德·斯拉希。我于2001年被绑架，被关押了超过14年，大部分时间在关塔那摩湾。
During this 14 years in Guantanamo, the United States government came to believe that he recruited into Al-Qaeda men who later became hijackers in the 9-11 attacks. But they never charged him with that, or anything else.
在关塔那摩的这14年里，美国政府开始相信他为基地组织招募了后来成为“9·11”恐怖袭击劫机者的人。但他们从未以那项罪名或任何其他罪名起诉他。
Mohamedou Slahi was tortured, on one occasion beaten quite badly. He was kept awake by loud music, made to stand for hours at a time, left shackled in a cold room. The torture stopped after a few months, but they kept him for another 13 years. A judge ruled that the government could prove that he had been in touch with people in Al-Qaeda and sometimes help them out, but failed to show more than that and didn't have enough evidence to hold him. So finally he was released.
穆罕默杜·斯拉希遭受了酷刑，有一次被打得很惨。他被大声的音乐折磨得无法入睡，被迫一站就是几个小时，被戴着镣铐留在冰冷的房间里。几个月后酷刑停止了，但他们又关押了他13年。法官裁定，政府只能证明他与基地组织成员有联系，有时帮助过他们，但未能证明更多内容，也没有足够的证据继续拘留他。所以他最终被释放了。
And if you've only heard of one Guantanamo detainee, this man, Mohamedou Slahi might be that guy. He wrote a book, originally called Guantanamo Diary, published while he was still locked up, became a cause for human rights groups and celebrities. There's a movie about him with Jodie Foster, and Benedict Cumberbatch, and Tahar Raheem.
如果你只听说过一个关塔那摩囚犯，这个人，穆罕默杜·斯拉希可能就是那个名字。他写了一本书，最初名为《关塔那摩日记》，在他还被关押时出版，成为了人权组织和名人们关注的焦点。有一部关于他的电影，由朱迪·福斯特、本尼迪克特·康伯巴奇和塔哈·拉希姆主演。
These days he is living in Mauritania. Maybe the most famous person in the country. People stop him on the street and at the beach. He married an American human rights lawyer, had a son, is writing another book, just published a novel. And the purpose of this video he was shooting was very particular. He wanted to issue an invitation to everyone who knew him at Guantanamo Bay, the guards and interrogators, everybody.
如今，他住在毛里塔尼亚。他可能是这个国家最出名的人。人们在街上和海滩上拦住他。他娶了一位美国人权律师，生了一个儿子，正在写另一本书，刚刚出版了一部小说。他拍摄这段视频的目的非常特别。他想向所有在关塔那摩湾认识他的人发出邀请，包括警卫、审讯员，所有人。
Some of you guys mistreated me, even tortured me. But I'm telling you wholeheartedly that I have forgiven you. I hold no grudge against you guys. Honest to God. I invite all of you to my house so we could drink tea and talk about the past. Thank you very much and God bless you.
你们中的一些人虐待了我，甚至折磨了我。但我全心全意地告诉你们，我已经原谅了你们。我没有记恨你们。向上帝发誓。我邀请你们所有人到我家来喝茶，聊聊过去。非常感谢，上帝保佑你们。
This invitation to tea, it's also at the very end of his book. And for a long time, nobody took him up on it. But then by chance one of the guards from Guantanamo noticed on Facebook that Mohamedou was out and messaged him.
这份喝茶的邀请，也写在他书的最后。很长一段时间里，没有人接受他的邀请。但后来，一位关塔那摩的警卫在脸书上偶然发现穆罕默杜获释了，并给他发了信息。
The guard's name is Scott, though Mohamedou knew him as Master Jedi. Guards didn't use their real names. They wore masks. Apparently there's a whole Star Wars thing going on. There was Master Yoda, Master Luke. Anyway, Scott, Jedi, was really young at the time. Got sent to Guantanamo and was assigned right away to Mohamedou their most high profile detainee.
这位警卫叫斯科特，尽管穆罕默杜认识他时称他为“绝地大师”。警卫不用真名。他们戴着面具。显然他们玩着一套《星球大战》的梗。有尤达大师、卢克大师。总之，斯科特（绝地）当时非常年轻。他被派往关塔那摩，并立刻被指派看守穆罕默杜，也就是他们最受关注的囚犯。
I remember going into that building scared to death because I was expecting someone about eight feet tall, 200 pounds that I didn't know what I was getting into as a young kid. But I opened up that screen and I see this skinny, little, tan man laying on the bed who looked like he didn't have a clue what was going on.
我记得走进那座大楼时吓得要死，因为我期待着一个身高八英尺、体重两百磅的人，作为一个年轻人，我不知道自己要面对什么。但我打开遮挡板，看到这个瘦小、晒得黝黑的男人躺在床上，看起来对发生的一切一无所知。
This audio that you're hearing was collected as part of this really remarkable documentary by a filmmaker who made it his mission to track down some of the guards and interrogators Mohamedou was reaching out to with his invitation to tea, to see if they would be willing to talk to him. The filmmaker who did this is John Goetz.
你听到的这段音频是由一位电影制作人整理的。他的一项使命就是追踪穆罕默杜发出茶会邀请后，试图联络的一些警卫和审讯员，看看他们是否愿意和他交谈。完成这项工作的制片人是约翰·格茨。
And back when Mohamedou was at Guantanamo, John was a reporter. He was living in Germany, writing for a German audience. And he started writing about Mohamedou because Mohamedou was one of the few people at Guantanamo with a German connection. Mohamedou had lived in Germany for 11 years.
在穆罕默杜还在关塔那摩时，约翰是一名记者。他住在德国，为德国受众撰稿。他开始报道穆罕默杜，因为穆罕默杜是关塔那摩少数与德国有联系的人之一。穆罕默杜在德国生活了11年。
And then when you look at his story, his story was just incredible. You know, he was the son of a camel herder, as part of a family with 12 kids, who ends up with this elite scholarship in Germany and becomes an engineer here, a successful engineer at one of the leading high tech companies of Germany. And then at the same time he's accused of having recruited the pilots for the September 11th attacks.
当你审视他的故事时，那简直不可思议。他是一个牧骆驼人的儿子，家里有12个孩子，最后获得了德国的精英奖学金，在那里成为了一名工程师，并在德国顶尖的高科技公司担任成功的工程师。但与此同时，他被指控为9月11日的袭击招募了飞行员。
After the United States concluded that it did not have the evidence for a case against Mohamedou and released him, John went to see him in Mauritania, meet him for the first time in person. And he asked about that invitation.
在美国得出结论称没有证据起诉穆罕默杜并将他释放后，约翰去毛里塔尼亚看了他，这是他们第一次亲身见面。他问到了那个邀请。
And I was wondering, was it a real invitation? Or did he really mean that?
我在想，那是真的邀请吗？他是真心的吗？
And did he?
他是真心的吗？
He did. He was more serious than I thought he'd be. When I met him, he had-- it was very recent that he had gotten out. And in many ways he was just kind of ripped out of the environment he had been in for 14 years. And he wasn't finished with what happened to him.
是的，他是。他比我想象的还要认真。当我见到他时——他获释不久。在很多方面，他就像刚从生活了14年的环境中被连根拔起。他还没从发生在他身上的事中走出来。
John says that Mohamedou's lawyers told Mohamedou, absolutely do not try to track down your former captors yourself for this invitation. It'll look like you're stalking them. But Mohamedou asked John, as an American journalist, could he try to find these people? He'd seen the TV documentary where John had done exactly that kind of tracking down for his story.
约翰说，穆罕默杜的律师曾告诉他，绝对不要为了这个邀请亲自去寻找你曾经的狱卒。看起来会像你在跟踪他们。但穆罕默杜作为一名美国记者请求约翰帮忙，能否尝试找到这些人？他看过电视纪录片，约翰曾在片中为他的报道做过类似的追踪。
And John said yes. He thought it could be a good film. And then spent two years searching for people Mohamedou had known in Guantanamo. He actually spoke with about a dozen of them. Three were willing to talk to Mohamedou all these years later about what had gone down. Two of those were people that John found, and then there was Scott, who, like I said, showed up out of the blue on his own.
约翰答应了。他觉得这能拍成一部好电影。随后，他花了两年时间寻找穆罕默杜在关塔那摩认识的人。他确实与大约十几个人谈过。其中三个人在这么多年后愿意与穆罕默杜谈谈当时的情况。其中两个人是约翰找到的，还有就是斯科特，就像我说的，他自己突然出现了。
Well, Scott was one of Mohamedou's guards in the period while Mohamedou was being tortured.
嗯，斯科特是穆罕默杜在遭受酷刑期间的警卫之一。
And does that mean that he saw the torture or participated in the torture?
那意味着他目睹或参与了酷刑吗？
Scott says he did not see the torture. Scott says he did not physically abuse Mohamedou. But Scott says it was his role to soften up Mohamedou.
斯科特说他没有目睹酷刑。斯科特说他没有身体虐待穆罕默杜。但斯科特说他的任务是“软化”穆罕默杜。
That means Scott prevented Mohamedou from ever praying, gave him meals at random times, sometimes Mohamedou only got 60 seconds to eat or take a shower. Pillow was Mohamedou's nickname at Guantanamo. Because after they tortured him and broke him, the first comfort they gave him as a reward was a pillow.
这意味着斯科特阻止穆罕默杜祈祷，在随机的时间给他送餐，有时穆罕默杜只有60秒来吃饭或洗澡。“枕头”是穆罕默杜在关塔那摩的绰号。因为在他们折磨他、击垮他之后，作为奖励给他的第一个安慰就是一个枕头。
Mohamedou's torture ended after a few months. Scott was there for about a month of that. And after the torture ended, everything between them was very different. For starters, they were allowed to talk to each other. And they talked a lot. Scott guarded him in 12 hour shifts for about a year more.
穆罕默杜的酷刑在几个月后停止了。斯科特参与了其中的一个月。酷刑停止后，他们之间的关系变得大不相同。首先，他们被允许交谈了。他们谈了很多。斯科特又看了他大约一年的12小时轮班。
So in that period they got to know each other quite well. And they played chess together. Apparently Mohamedou won every time they played. You know, they watched films together. And ended up at the end of this having quite kind of a good connection.
在那段时间里，他们彼此了解得很深。他们在一起下国际象棋。显然他们下棋时穆罕默杜每次都赢。他们一起看电影。最后，他们建立了一种相当不错的连接。
I know we barbecued a few times, gave him some of the food. We used to mess with him a little bit. Because where his toilet was on the floor, there was a hole in the back and you could be like, Pillow, Pillow, and talk to him from that. And he'd be like, my toilets talking, you know?
我知道我们烧烤过几次，给他吃过一些食物。我们过去常捉弄他。因为他地板上的厕所后面有个洞，你可以像这样，‘枕头，枕头’，从那里跟他说话。他会说，‘我的厕所在跟我说话’，你知道吗？
It wasn't nothing to harm with him. It was just us being bored at that time. So I would go back there and just be like, Pillow, Pillow, it's your toilet. You know? So to me that was pretty comical. So don't hate me for that one, but I thought it was funny.
这没什么恶意。只是那时我们太无聊了。所以我回去只是会说，‘枕头，枕头，我是你的厕所。’你知道吗？所以对我来说这很滑稽。别因为这个讨厌我，但我那时觉得很好笑。
Scott told John that after he left Guantanamo, he would think about Mohamedou and dream about him. And back home in the state's at church, they give a talk about forgiveness and reconciliation that made him think that he should reach out.
斯科特告诉约翰，离开关塔那摩后，他会想起穆罕默杜，梦到他。回到美国的教堂里，他们谈论宽恕与和解的话题，这让他觉得他应该联系他。
So when John was filming Scott in Kentucky, at one point John pulled out his iPhone and suggested they call Mohamedou right then. Two of Scott's kids were there. One was playing Minecraft. There was a bunch of pets around. And they got him on the phone.
所以当约翰在肯塔基拍摄斯科特时，约翰拿出iPhone，建议他们现在就给穆罕默杜打个电话。斯科特的两个孩子也在场。一个在玩《我的世界》。周围有一堆宠物。他们接通了电话。
Hey, Pillow.
嘿，枕头。
No fucking way!
不是吧！
Hey. Watch your mouth before I tie you up. Huh?
嘿。说话小心点，不然我就把你捆起来。嗯？
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
I got fat, man.
我变胖了，伙计。
Man, you would have been-- I like your beard, man.
伙计，你本该……我喜欢你的胡子，伙计。
I like your haircut.
我喜欢你的发型。
It's beautiful.
真漂亮。
I like that haircut.
我喜欢那个发型。
Thank you very much.
非常感谢。
You're shiny.
你很有光泽。
That's automatic haircut. It fell off.
这是自动发型。它掉光了。
Watch your mouth before I tie you up?
说话小心点，不然我就把你捆起来？
Yeah. That's the first thing he really says to him.
是啊。这是他真正对他说出的第一句话。
So I feel like I never really caused you any harm, but I wanted to seek forgiveness. You know, because as a kid, a 20-year-old kid, I didn't know what I was doing.
我觉得我从来没有真正伤害过你，但我想要寻求宽恕。你知道，因为作为一个孩子，一个20岁的孩子，我不知道我在做什么。
You're right.
你说得对。
Yeah.
是啊。
Mohamedou says you're right, but then he brings up how some of the guards used to make him take off his orange uniform and then use it to wipe down the entire cell, including the toilet, and then put the uniform back on, and how bad that felt.
穆罕默杜说你说得对，但他提到了有些警卫曾强迫他脱掉橙色囚服，然后用它擦拭整个牢房，包括厕所，再把囚服穿回去，那感觉有多糟糕。
And I was so scared.
我当时非常害怕。
And how in that cell all he had was prayer, but Scott wouldn't let him pray.
在那间牢房里，他唯一能做的就是祈祷，但斯科特不让他祈祷。
I remember one day I ask you, why do you prevent me from praying? Why you prevent me from doing my fasting and so-- and then you said, I don't know. I don't know. Maybe I go to Hell for that.
我记得有一天我问你，为什么阻止我祈祷？为什么阻止我禁食，等等……然后你说，我不知道。我不知道。也许我会因此下地狱。
Well, was that-- was that me?
嗯，那是……那是我的话吗？
Yeah, I think it was you.
是的，我想是你。
No.
不。
You always discussed about religion and so.
你总是讨论宗教之类的问题。
Yeah, it's a big deal to me. But now that I'm at church, I realize that everyone has their own religion. And it's fine. It's totally acceptable.
是啊，这对我来说很重要。但现在在教堂，我意识到每个人都有自己的信仰。这很好。完全可以接受。
Correct.
没错。
I have nothing against anyone else with a different religion. It doesn't bother me.
我对任何有不同信仰的人都没有意见。这不困扰我。
Same God. Same God.
同一个上帝。同一个上帝。
Yep.
是啊。
You know, they talk for a few more minutes. It's not a long phone call. The line breaks down and freezes, like right in the middle of the call.
他们又聊了几分钟。电话通话时间不长。线路断开了，像卡住了一样，就在通话中间。
Anyway, I just want to say, no harm done, and thank you for reaching out. And--
总之，我只想说，没有造成伤害，谢谢你的联络。而且——
You might not say there's no harm done, but you lost 14 years. I think we're freezing up again.
你可能不会说没有造成伤害，但你失去了14年。我想我们又卡住了。
Yes.
是的。
Yeah.
是啊。
And then, they kind of reconnect, and basically, say goodbye.
然后，他们重新接通了，基本上道了别。
Well, look, I'm going to let you go to bed. And it was amazing talking to you.
好了，听着，我要让你去睡觉了。和你聊天真是太棒了。
Same here, bud.
我也一样，哥们。
It was like talking to an old friend again. It was awesome.
就像又和一个老朋友聊天一样。真是太棒了。
Same here.
我也一样。
I love you!
我爱你！
[BACKGROUND VOICES]
[背景人声]
Dad.
爸爸。
I love you, man.
我爱你，伙计。
Oh, wait, does Mohamedou say, I love you, man?
等等，穆罕默杜说了“我爱你，伙计”吗？
He says, I love you, man. Yeah.
他说，“我爱你，伙计”。是的。
Goodbye.
再见。
[CHILD TALKING IN BACKGROUND]
[背景孩子谈话声]
God, I miss that guy. Just talking to him for just right then, you know, brings all the emotions back. You know, just-- I honestly do love that guy. You know, I think he's an amazing guy.
上帝，我想念那个家伙。刚才仅仅是和他聊了一会儿，你知道，就让所有的情绪都回来了。你知道，只是……我确实真的爱那个家伙。你知道，我认为他是个了不起的人。
I don't know why I said it, but it just came over me. You know, just to know that I still have that connection with someone is absolutely amazing.
我不知道我为什么会说出来，但那种感觉油然而生。你知道，知道我还能和某人保持那种联系，感觉真是太奇妙了。
We're devoting the rest of our program today to two other calls, which go very differently from the one that you just heard with Scott. These two calls, they were with people who were way tougher on Mohamedou when he was locked up. These are people who interrogated him back then. These are people who have not softened towards him today.
我们今天节目的剩余部分将专门讨论另外两个通话，情况与你刚才听到的斯科特的通话大不相同。这两个通话的对象是在他被关押时对他更狠的人。这些人曾审讯他。这些人今天对他并没有软化。
And what's so interesting about hearing these conversations is that Guantanamo has been such a black box for 20 years. And these conversations with Mohamedou Ould Slahi, you'll hear, give this glimpse at how the Americans and the detainees interacted in this way that I, for sure, had never heard before. These conversations that are like sparring matches or, I don't know, mental chess games. From WBZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
听到这些对话非常有趣，因为关塔那摩20年来一直是个黑匣子。正如你将听到的，这些与穆罕默杜·乌尔德·斯拉希的对话提供了一瞥，展示了美国人和囚犯之间那种我肯定从未听说过的互动方式。这些对话就像一场拳击比赛，或者，我不知道，一场心理象棋游戏。来自芝加哥WBZ，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
OK, so before we get to these calls, because this comes up in the calls, you need to know a little bit about how Mohamedou ended up in Guantanamo in the first place.
好的，在进入这些通话之前——因为这在对话中会出现——你需要了解一点关于穆罕默杜当初是如何被关进关塔那摩的。
Well, from the point of view of the US government, there were a lot of things that made Mohamedou suspicious.
从美国政府的角度来看，有很多事情让穆罕默杜显得很可疑。
Again, this is journalist-filmmaker, John Goetz.
再次说明，这是记者兼电影制作人约翰·格茨。
Number one, he had gone to Afghanistan in the early 1990s and was actually a part of Al-Qaeda at that phase, and part of, kind of, the Osama bin Laden wing of the mujahideen.
第一，他曾在90年代初前往阿富汗，实际上在那一阶段是基地组织的一员，属于圣战者中奥萨马·本·拉登那一派。
You may remember, back in the 1980s, the US had supported the mujahideen in their fight against the Soviets in Afghanistan. Mohamedou says that after he left Afghanistan in the early '90s, he broke with Al-Qaeda.
你可能还记得，80年代时美国曾支持圣战者对抗苏联在阿富汗的战斗。穆罕默杜说，90年代初他离开阿富汗后，就与基地组织决裂了。
But his cousin became one of the top leaders of Al-Qaeda. He even called-- his cousin even called Mohamedou while he was in Germany from Osama bin Laden's satellite phone.
但他的表弟成为了基地组织的高层领导人之一。他甚至打过电话……他的表弟甚至在穆罕默杜身处德国时，通过奥萨马·本·拉登的卫星电话打给他。
Mohamedou also had contact with a bunch of people who ended up committing terrorist acts. Like, he was close friends with a man who later was connected to a synagogue bombing in Tunisia. He attended a mosque in Canada, where a major terrorist plot was planned.
穆罕默杜还与一群最终实施恐怖袭击的人有过接触。比如，他与后来涉及突尼斯犹太教堂爆炸案的一个人关系密切。他在加拿大的一座清真寺礼拜，那里曾策划过重大的恐怖袭击阴谋。
He had at least one of the organizers of the 9/11 attacks stay his apartment in Duisburg in October, 1999. Some say that even two of the hijackers were there with him that evening, and he kind of encouraged them to go to Afghanistan.
“9·11”袭击的组织者中至少有一人曾于1999年10月在他位于杜伊斯堡的公寓里住过。有人说那天晚上甚至有两名劫机者和他在一起，他甚至鼓励他们去阿富汗。
But the fact that he had contact with all of these different people-- all of these things together, you know, it's kind of like, is there an explanation that's not ominous about Mohamedou? That was kind of like the position of the US government at the time.
但事实上，他与这么多不同的人接触过……所有这些加在一起，你知道，就像是，对于穆罕默杜有没有一种不是那么不祥的解释？这在当时是美国政府的一种立场。
Well, no, that sounds pretty bad. What does Mohamedou say about that?
嗯，不，这听起来相当糟糕。穆罕默杜对此怎么说？
Well, Mohamedou says-- in each and every case, he gives a simple explanation as for why it happened. I mean, he explains, for example, that his cousin called because he needed Mohamedou to transfer some money to a family member in Mauritania. He says, regarding the mosque in Canada that was involved in planning this terrorist attack, you know, that there were thousands of people that went to the mosque and he never met the guy who was involved who planned the attack.
好吧，穆罕默杜说……在每一个案例中，他都给出了一个简单的解释，说明为什么会发生那样的事。我是说，他解释说，例如，他的表弟打来电话是因为需要穆罕默杜把一些钱转给毛里塔尼亚的一位家庭成员。关于那个涉及策划恐怖袭击的加拿大清真寺，他说，有成千上万的人去那座清真寺，他从未见过那个参与策划袭击的人。
OK, and so with that, I think that everybody has caught up with the basic facts about Mohamedou, and we are ready to turn to Act 1.
好的，既然这样，我想每个人都已经了解了关于穆罕默杜的基本事实，我们准备进入第一幕。
Act 1, Sydney. So the reporter for the rest of the hour is going to be Bastian Berbner, who's been on our show before. He's actually been working with John Goetz for over a year. As John made his film, Bastian made a podcast series from the story, for German Public Radio. Here's Bastian.
第一幕，悉尼。所以，这一小时剩余部分的记者将是巴斯蒂安·伯布纳，他之前也上过我们的节目。他其实已经和约翰·格茨合作超过一年了。当约翰制作电影时，巴斯蒂安为德国公共广播电台制作了一个关于这个故事的播客系列。这是巴斯蒂安。
After years of searching for Mohamedou's captors, John eventually got a tip about a woman who the person said probably knows more about Mohamedou's case than anyone else. That woman's name was Sydney. We are not using her last name here.
在寻找穆罕默杜的狱卒多年后，约翰最终得到了一个关于一名女性的消息，那人说这个女人可能比任何人都更了解穆罕默杜的案子。那个女人的名字叫悉尼。我们在这里不使用她的姓氏。
Back in 2003, she was in military intelligence, working as an analyst on Mohamedou's case. John found her in a Texas suburb. She's a teacher now, and she agreed to talk. Mohamedou Ould Slahi was the case of her life. In Guantanamo, she spent weeks questioning him, day in, day out, which is rare for someone who isn't an interrogator.
早在2003年，她在军事情报部门工作，担任穆罕默杜案的分析师。约翰在德克萨斯州的一个郊区找到了她。她现在是一名老师，并同意接受采访。穆罕默杜·乌尔德·斯拉希是她一生中最重要的案子。在关塔那摩，她花了数周时间审问他，日复一日，这对于非审讯员来说很罕见。
I told Slahi-- I was like, I always call him my Gitmo boyfriend, because I know more about him than anybody else who was in my life at that time. And yeah, so he was in-- on the cover of the Gitmo magazine, or paper, and he wrote on it, "to my girlfriend, never forget our times together."
我告诉斯拉希——我就说，我总是叫他“我的关塔那摩男友”，因为那时我对他了解的比我生活中任何人都要多。是的，他当时在关塔那摩杂志或报纸的封面上，他在上面写道：“给我的女朋友，永远不要忘记我们在一起的时光。”
Sydney was a young soldier when 9/11 happened. From then on, she says her life only knew one purpose-- to catch Al-Qaeda terrorists. She was at work before anyone else and stayed after everyone had left. No partner, no vacations for 15 years.
“9·11”发生时，悉尼还是一名年轻的士兵。从那时起，她说她的人生只有一个目标——抓捕基地组织恐怖分子。她比任何人都先到公司，在所有人都走后才离开。没有伴侣，15年没有休假。
When I was in the thick of AQ every day, I had pictures of dead guys next to pictures of my family on my desk. And people were like, how do you have that?
当我每天深入基地组织的核心时，我的桌子上放着死人的照片和家人的照片。人们问我，你怎么会有这个？
Wait a minute. Tell me about that. What kind of pictures?
等等。跟我说说那个。什么样的照片？
Oh, some of them were pretty gruesome. I remember one was-- the dude's face literally was blown off. Like, it's a reminder. Like, that dude would have killed me if given an opportunity, and I'm doing everything I can to help track these people down, so they don't get those opportunities to hurt me or my family.
哦，有些很可怕。我记得有一张是——那家伙的脸简直被打烂了。就像是一个提醒。如果给那个家伙机会，他会杀了我，我正在尽我所能帮助追踪这些人，这样他们就没有机会伤害我或我的家人。
When John asked Sydney if she wanted to talk to Mohamedou, she was reluctant at first, but eventually, she said yes. She still believes he was a key Al-Qaeda terrorist.
当约翰问悉尼是否愿意与穆罕默杜谈谈时，她起初很犹豫，但最终答应了。她仍然相信他曾是一名关键的基地组织恐怖分子。
Not a fighter or a suicide bomber or anything of that sort, no. Him being super intelligent, charismatic, speaking five languages, she thinks his job was more in the background, recruiting terrorists for Al-Qaeda, including the 9/11 hijackers.
不是战士或自杀式炸弹袭击者之类的人，不是。她认为他非常聪明、有魅力，会说五种语言，他的工作更多是在幕后，为基地组织招募恐怖分子，包括9/11劫机者。
He at least served 14 years in jail. That's something. Was it enough? Absolutely not. Not at all.
他至少坐了14年牢。这算是一回事。够了吗？绝对不够。一点也不。
What would have been enough?
什么样的程度才算够了？
Personally, death.
个人而言，死刑。
For a while, I thought, she is so convinced of his guilt, she must have something to back this up. But I talked to her for hours about it. Days. And the stuff she kept bringing up, it either didn't check out when I looked into it. Or the judge had seen it, too, and still ordered Mohamedou's release.
有一段时间我心想，她对他的罪行如此确信，她一定有什么证据支撑。但我跟她聊了几个小时，甚至几天。她不断提到的那些事情，当我调查时，要么对不上号。要么法官也看过这些证据，但依然下令释放穆罕默杜。
Sydney worked on Mohamedou's case for years. She traveled to Mauritania, interviewed his ex-wife. She says, in Guantanamo, she pushed to have him isolated from the other detainees, but she never got a confession out of him. Now, 17 years later, she thought, he was a free man. Maybe she could finally get him to admit something.
悉尼在穆罕默杜的案子上工作了多年。她去了毛里塔尼亚，采访了他的前妻。她说，在关塔那摩，她曾力推将他与其他囚犯隔离，但她从未从他嘴里得到过供词。现在，17年过去了，她想，他是个自由人了。也许她终于能让他承认点什么。
While the film crew set up in her house, she started writing down the list of topics she wanted to cover with him, like 9/11. She was sure he knew about the attacks beforehand. Then his cousin, the one who called him from bin Laden's phone, and Canada. In late 1999, Mohamedou moved there for two months. Sydney was always convinced that he was the head of an Al-Qaeda cell there.
当摄制组在她家布置设备时，她开始列出她想和他探讨的话题清单，比如9/11。她确信他在袭击前就知道。还有他的表弟，那个用本·拉登的电话给他打过电话的人，以及加拿大。1999年底，穆罕默杜在那里住了两个月。悉尼一直确信他是那里基地组织分支的头目。
[CHUCKLES] He gets so upset when you talk about Canada, and that's definitely one of the topics I'd really want to bring up with him.
[轻笑] 当你提到加拿大时，他会变得非常心烦，那绝对是我真心想和他探讨的话题之一。
Meanwhile, John and I were with Mohamedou in Mauritania. John asked him what he remembered about Sydney.
与此同时，约翰和我正在毛里塔尼亚和穆罕默杜在一起。约翰问他还记得悉尼吗。
She was dying, thirsty, dying to find something. Because that was a very big thing in Guantanamo Bay. If you break up a "terrorist," quote unquote. And she was like, oh my god, when is this going to happen?
她当时快渴死了，极度渴望发现点什么。因为这在关塔那摩湾是一件大事。如果你破获了一个“恐怖分子”，所谓的。她说，天哪，这什么时候才会发生？
When am I going to get my break? I was her break. And not having that break in me, it was like-- I would imagine it would have been very hard for her. But today, maybe I will give her the break.
我什么时候能有突破？我就是她的突破口。而从我这里没有得到那个突破，我想那对她来说一定很难。但今天，也许我会给她这个突破。
Why are you doing this?
你为什么这么做？
I just like-- you know, some people like to watch horror movies because the horror is not-- they are not part of it. This is the first time I get to watch a horror movie and I'm not a part of it.
我只是……你知道，有些人喜欢看恐怖电影，因为恐怖并非……他们不是其中的一部分。这是我第一次看恐怖电影，而我不再是其中的一部分。
I'm removed from her. She has no power over me. I just want to face her where she has no power over me. Absolutely no power. She can't do nothing to me. That, to me, is very important.
我已经脱离了她。她对我毫无权力。我只是想在她对我没有任何权力的时候面对她。绝对没有任何权力。她不能对我做任何事。这对我来说非常重要。
OK, we're ready. Are you ready, Mohamedou?
好了，我们准备好了。你准备好了吗，穆罕默杜？
I don't know. It depends.
我不知道。看情况。
Oh, you don't know? What does it depend on?
哦，你不知道？取决于什么？
[LAUGHS] First, I want to say, to tell you that I'm so happy to see you again, and that I'm truly, truly sorry that Trump lost the elections.
[笑] 首先，我想说，告诉你我很高兴再次见到你，而且我真的、真的很遗憾特朗普输掉了选举。
[LAUGHS] You would have voted for Trump? Oh, Mohamedou!
[笑] 你会投票给特朗普吗？哦，穆罕默杜！
Me? I don't know. I don't have the right to vote.
我？我不知道。我没有投票权。
No, would you have? If you could have, would you have voted for that man?
不，你会吗？如果可以的话，你会投票给那个人吗？
No, I like to watch drama unfold.
不会，我喜欢看戏上演。
[SYDNEY LAUGHS]
[悉尼笑]
I don't like to be a part of it.
我不喜欢成为其中的一部分。
It was a dra-- oh, I think you lie on that part. You are always a part of drama, Mohamedou. I'm happy to see you, too.
那是一出戏剧……哦，我觉得你在那部分撒谎。你总是戏的一部分，穆罕默杜。我也很高兴见到你。
I remember, a few minutes into the call, John and I, we looked at each other like, what the hell is going on? It's almost like hostile flirting or something. Later, she told us, that's how you have to talk to Mohamedou to get anything out of him.
我记得，通话几分钟后，约翰和我面面相觑，心想，这到底是怎么回事？这几乎像是带有敌意的调情什么的。后来她告诉我们，你必须用那种方式和穆罕默杜交谈才能从他嘴里得到任何东西。
The first thing Sydney brings up is his book. In the original draft, she saw, Mohamedou only briefly refers to her, and only by the nickname the guards gave her-- TOF. It stands for Tons Of Fun. Sydney says they called her that because she had a big chest.
悉尼提到的第一件事是他的书。在初稿中她看到，穆罕默杜只简短地提到了她，而且只用了警卫给她的绰号——TOF。意思是“一大堆乐趣”（Tons Of Fun）。悉尼说他们叫她这个是因为她的胸部很大。
And I think you had me in there as TOF. Is that right?
我想你把我写成TOF了。对吧？
That's correct. That's correct. Yes.
没错。没错。是的。
So--
那么——
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交叉对话]
What did that stand for--
那是代表什么——
Why did you send--
为什么你送——
--Mohamedou?
——穆罕默杜？
I don't know. This is one of the guards. You can't do that.
我不知道。这是其中一个警卫。你不能那样做。
Come on. Let's hear it, because I heard what it was for, but I want you to tell me.
来吧。说出来，因为我听说过它是为了什么，但我想要你亲口告诉我。
I don't want to be kidnapped again.
我不想再被绑架了。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
(LAUGHING) I don't want to be kidnapped again.
(笑) 我不想再被绑架了。
Hey, I am not that powerful.
嘿，我没那么大权力。
No, but-- no, no, no, but I will tell you something.
不，但是……不，不，不，但我会告诉你一些事。
Are you scared to tell me what that means? Come on. You're not going to offend me. I already know what it means.
你是不是害怕告诉我那意味着什么？来吧。你不会冒犯我的。我已经知道那是什么意思了。
Sydney slips into the conversation one of the topics she wanted to discuss-- Mohamedou's cousin, Abu Hafs, the high-ranking Al-Qaeda guy. Today, Abu Hafs lives down the road from Mohamedou, in a mansion. He was never captured.
悉尼在谈话中顺带提到了她想讨论的话题之一——穆罕默杜的表弟，阿布·哈夫斯，那个基地组织的高层。今天，阿布·哈夫斯就住在穆罕默杜路下面的一座豪宅里。他从未被捕。
When I was in Mauritania, I visited him. And it was kind of mind-boggling to see that this key Al-Qaeda guy is not only free, but he's actually very well respected in Mauritania, which is a partner of the United States.
我在毛里塔尼亚时去看过他。看到这位关键的基地组织人员不仅自由，而且在毛里塔尼亚还受到高度尊重，这让人难以置信，毕竟毛里塔尼亚是美国的伙伴。
Because Abu Hafs, as smart in his own right, is not as smart as you. Have you talked to him?
因为阿布·哈夫斯，虽然他自己很聪明，但他没有你聪明。你和他谈过吗？
Very little.
很少。
Oh, yeah?
哦，是吗？
But you are a very smart person. How could you make a judgment? You never met him. You never talked to him. I'm a little bit--
但你是个非常聪明的人。你怎么能做评判呢？你从未见过他。你从未和他交谈过。我有点……
Oh, judgment about his intelligence?
哦，关于他智慧的评判？
Yes. May I challenge your idea?
是的。我可以挑战你的观点吗？
Of course.
当然。
You said--
你说——
Of course.
当然。
You said he's not as smart as me.
你说他没有我聪明。
Yeah.
是啊。
So how could you make that judgment without being with him, interrogating him, too?
那你怎么能在没和他在一起、也没审讯过他的情况下做出那种评判呢？
I never interrogated you. We always talked.
我从未审讯过你。我们一直是在交谈。
OK, you brought me tea, you brought me biscuit. We dated for a couple of times.
好的，你给我送茶，给我送饼干。我们还约会了几次。
[SYDNEY LAUGHS]
[悉尼笑]
Let's put it that way. So however, I will challenge that idea and tell you--
就这么说吧。总之，我会挑战那个观点并告诉你——
OK.
好的。
I will say he's smarter than me. Because he had $25 million bounty on his head. I had $0 bounty on my head. He evaded American capture until American craziness evaporated and they say he's not part of 9/11.
我会说他比我聪明。因为他头上有2500万美元的悬赏。我头上是0美元的悬赏。他躲避了美国的抓捕，直到美国人的疯狂消退，他们才说他不是9/11的一部分。
And he snuck himself-- smuggled himself through continents, and he's back in Mauritania, living his life very well with his kid, with his family, without fear, without nothing. I would say, compared to some person who was kidnapped in a mafia-like operation, taken to Jordan, not to the United States, from Jordan to Afghanistan, from Gaza to Guantanamo Bay. I would say, any given day, person number one wins the smart card, any given day. So that's my challenge.
他把自己偷渡过了各个大陆，现在回到了毛里塔尼亚，和他的孩子、家人过得非常好，没有恐惧，什么都没有。我会说，相比于一个在黑手党式的行动中被绑架、被带到约旦、没带到美国、从约旦到阿富汗、从加沙到关塔那摩湾的人，我会说，在任何一天，第一个人赢了智慧卡。每一天。这就是我的挑战。
[BOTH LAUGH]
[两人笑]
OK, well, I will say this.
好吧，那我得说这一点。
OK.
好的。
That you, your purpose in Al-Qaeda was totally different than Abu Hafs. What do you call him, by the way?
你，你在基地组织的目的和阿布·哈夫斯完全不同。顺便说一句，你怎么称呼他？
Thank you, ma'am, bin Laden-- Madam bin Laden. I did not know that.
谢谢你，女士，本·拉登……本·拉登夫人。我不知道这一点。
So his purpose, totally different than your purpose, for Al-Qaeda.
所以他的目的，和你在基地组织的目的完全不同。
Thank you for telling me about my purpose.
谢谢你告诉我我的目的。
Oh, you know this.
哦，你知道的。
I'm so--
我太……
You know this, Mohamedou.
你知道的，穆罕默杜。
I'm so, so eager to hear about this. Give me the update. Give the update and give my next mission, too, while you're at it.
我非常、非常渴望听听这个。给我更新一下。再顺便告诉我我的下一个任务是什么吧。
About an hour into the call, Sydney finally brings up Canada, the things she says Mohamedou never wanted to talk about. She's convinced that he was involved in the Millennium plot, a plan to blow up Los Angeles airport in late 1999. It failed when an Algerian man was arrested crossing the border from Canada with a car full of explosives. Before that, he had attended the same mosque in Montreal as Muhamedou, which is why the Canadian government started looking into Mohamedou.
通话进行到大约一小时，悉尼终于提到了加拿大，也就是她说穆罕默杜从不想谈论的事。她确信他参与了“千禧年阴谋”，即1999年底炸毁洛杉矶机场的计划。这失败了，因为一名阿尔及利亚人在穿越边境时被捕，车里装满了炸药。在此之前，他曾在蒙特利尔的同一座清真寺礼拜，这就是加拿大政府开始调查穆罕默杜的原因。
I always-- OK, so this is going way, way back, way, way back. And now, Canada, your favorite place on Earth, Canada.
我总是……好吧，这要追溯到很早很早以前。现在，加拿大，你地球上最喜欢的地方，加拿大。
Canada. Who would have thought?
加拿大。谁会想到呢？
I know. Who would have thought this young Mauritanian kid would want to go and live in Canada? After living in Germany.
我知道。谁会想到这个年轻的毛里塔尼亚孩子会想要去加拿大生活？在德国生活过之后。
Yes.
是的。
Which-- Germany is fantastic. I love Germany.
德国真是太棒了。我爱德国。
Yes. Oh, I agree with you. Fuck Canada.
是的。哦，我同意你。去他的加拿大。
[LAUGHS] I know you hated the Canadians.
[笑] 我知道你讨厌加拿大人。
Not the-- I love the Canadians. I hate what the government did to me.
不……我爱加拿大人。我讨厌政府对我做的事。
Yeah, I remember. I remember when you said--
是啊，我记得。我记得你说过——
Sucking up to American government. I hate that.
去讨好美国政府。我讨厌那样。
They were always up my ass. This is what you did. They were always up my ass. That's what you would say.
他们总是粘着我。这就是你做的。他们总是粘着我。你会这么说。
Yes, absolutely.
是的，绝对。
Why do you think they were always up your ass?
你为什么觉得他们总是粘着你？
I tell you why, because American told them, this is a very bad guy. He's a, quote unquote, "terrorist," which is a fucking political term, you know.
我告诉你为什么，因为美国人告诉他们，这是一个非常坏的家伙。他是一个，所谓的，“恐怖分子”，这是一个该死的政治术语，你知道。
What, terrorist?
什么，恐怖分子？
Yes. You cannot, for instance-- in the United States, you cannot say KKK is a terrorist group, because it would not fly.
是的。你不能，例如……在美国，你不能说三K党是一个恐怖组织，因为那行不通。
They both say this is how their conversations went in Guantanamo. She would bring up topics she wanted answers on. He would swat her away. And this here is a good example. She asks about Canada, and within seconds, he talks about the KKK and American bigotry. Eventually, Sydney steers the conversation back to Canada, and to his cousin, Abu Hafs, whose real name, by the way, is Mahfouz.
他们都说这就是他们在关塔那摩进行对话的方式。她会提出她想要答案的话题。他会把她打发走。这是一个很好的例子。她询问加拿大，几秒钟内他就谈到了三K党和美国的偏执。最终，悉尼将谈话引回加拿大，以及他的表弟阿布·哈夫斯，顺便说一句，他的真名是马赫福兹。
Terrorism is a political term.
恐怖主义是一个政治术语。
We're talking about, why was Canada up your ass.
我们谈论的是，为什么加拿大老盯着你。
OK, I tell you why.
好的，我告诉你为什么。
OK.
好的。
Because when I came to Canada, so I had a phone call with my cousin. He called me.
因为当我来到加拿大时，我和我表弟通了一个电话。他给我打了电话。
Yeah, that-- do you ever just go, man, fuck you, Mahfouz, look what you did to my life? Do you ever say that? Did you ever once think that?
是啊，那种……你有没有想过，伙计，去他的，马赫福兹，看看你对我生活做了什么？你有没有这么说过？你有没有哪怕一次想过这个？
Every day.
每一天。
Yeah?
是吗？
Every day.
每一天。
A few hours before their call, a trailer for the movie about Muhamedou had been released. It's called The Mauritanian. Muhamedou insisted on showing it to Sydney.
在通话前几个小时，关于穆罕默杜的电影预告片发布了。片名叫《毛里塔尼亚人》。穆罕默杜坚持要给悉尼看。
A lot of drama right there, Mohamedou.
那里面有太多的戏剧性了，穆罕默杜。
[MOHAMEDOU LAUGHS]
[穆罕默杜笑]
For someone who said they don't want to be in a lot of drama, that's a lot of drama.
对于一个声称不想卷入太多戏剧性的人来说，那真是太戏剧了。
Thank you for congratulating me.
谢谢你祝贺我。
You know what bothers me about that, Mohamedou? And this is one of those things. These are one of those, like, those unresolved issues that I wanted to talk to you about.
你知道关于那点什么让我感到困扰吗，穆罕默杜？这是其中之一。这些是……那些我想和你谈谈的未解决的问题。
Yeah, you will get your chance, you know. But today, I'm running the show.
是啊，你会得到机会的，你知道。但今天，我是主角。
OK. You've always run the show, just so you're aware.
好的。你一直是主角，只是让你知道一下。
[LAUGHS] I take that as a compliment.
[笑] 我把那当作赞美。
Take it as you will.
随你怎么想。
How did you mean it?
你是什么意思？
I took-- you've always had your way about you, Mohamedou. And your role was always the one of recruiter, and you've done that successfully your entire life. So that's what I mean.
我是说……你一直有你自己的那一套，穆罕默杜。你的角色一直是招募者，你一生都成功地做到了这一点。这就是我的意思。
Thank you so much. So I'm very sorry that you believe that I'm an evil man. But I can live with that, because you have no power over me.
非常感谢。所以我很抱歉你认为我是一个邪恶的人。但我可以接受，因为你对我没有任何权力。
No, 'cause you won.
不，因为你赢了。
Today, I'm going to go back--
今天，我要回去——
Yeah, I agree with that.
是啊，我同意那点。
I go back to my home, I drink tea, I will sleep, I will watch movies. I will not go back to the cell. And you will not try to report, Mohamedou Ould Slahi didn't comment on him recruiting. God knows that I am not a recruiter for Al-Qaeda or any organization. That's between me and Allah and the people who believe me, and there is no fucking shred of evidence that the US government could represent at the court of law that I was.
我回到我的家，我喝茶，我会睡觉，我会看电影。我不会回到那个牢房。你也不会尝试报道，穆罕默杜·乌尔德·斯拉希没有对他招募一事发表评论。上帝知道我不是基地组织或任何组织的招募者。这是我和安拉之间以及相信我的人之间的事情，美国政府在法庭上拿不出该死的哪怕一丝证据证明我是。
And that Judge Robertson, he's not my brother. He's not a Muslim. He's not an Arab. He's not an African. He's a fucking American conservative.
罗伯逊法官，他不是我的兄弟。他不是穆斯林。他不是阿拉伯人。他不是非洲人。他是一个该死的美国保守派。
Judge Robertson was the person who ruled in Mohamedou's habeas case. I'm not sure, by the way, if he saw himself as a conservative. He looked at the evidence the US government produced against Mohamedou and said, that's not enough to hold him. It actually took another six years for him to get released, because the Obama administration appealed the judge's ruling. He got out in 2016.
罗伯逊法官是穆罕默杜人身保护令案件的裁决人。顺便说一句，我不确定他是否认为自己是保守派。他看了美国政府针对穆罕默杜提出的证据，并说那不足以拘留他。实际上他花了又六年才获释，因为奥巴马政府对法官的裁决提起了上诉。他在2016年才出来。
So OK--
所以好的——
But I must say that--
但我必须说——
Are you ready to get back to Canada?
你准备好谈谈加拿大了吗？
I must have to say that I have to go in very, very-- in five minutes.
我必须说我必须非常、非常……在五分钟内离开。
What?
什么？
Yes. I cannot stay longer, because--
是的。我不能再待了，因为——
Can you just let her-- she has a few more points.
能不能让她——她还有几个要点。
I know, I know, but I don't have time to finish them. But you could organize another call. But I'm not staying.
我知道，我知道，但我没时间谈完了。但你可以组织下一次通话。但我不能再待了。
So I do want-- I respect your time 100%, and I understand that you want to go home, and it's been a long day. But I really think that you and I both would like to get to the end of something.
我百分之百尊重你的时间，我明白你想回家，而且这是漫长的一天。但我真的认为你和我都会想谈完点什么的。
Absolutely. I welcome you absolutely, and I have no secret. It's so good to catch up with you. So good. I'm so happy.
绝对。我绝对欢迎你，我没有任何秘密。能和你叙旧真是太好了。太好了。我很高兴。
You, too, Mohamedou.
你也是，穆罕默杜。
And thank you so much for agreeing to talk to me.
非常感谢你同意和我交谈。
Absolutely. You, too. Thank you.
绝对。你也是。谢谢。
This is only the first. Thank you, too. Bye.
这只是第一个。谢谢。再见。
Bye.
再见。
Immediately after the call, Sydney turns to one of the film's producers.
通话结束后，悉尼立即转向电影制片人之一。
You might not have seen what I saw. He left on purpose. Purpose, he ended that, because he knows what I'm going to ask him-- the whole Canada thing. And you saw, he got exactly upset, and I couldn't even go into it. That's how he behaves.
你可能没看到我看到的。他是故意的。他是故意结束的，因为他知道我要问他什么——关于加拿大的一切。你看到了，他变得非常心烦，我甚至都无法深入谈下去。这就是他的行为方式。
For Sydney, it was the same as it had always been.
对悉尼来说，这和往常一样。
But for Mohamedou, this round felt very different. Right after the call, we were in the backseat of a car, driving to the hotel where I was staying in Mauritania. I'd been interviewing him for days at that point and had never seen him so giddy.
但对穆罕默杜来说，这一轮感觉大不相同。通话后，我们坐在车后座，正开车去我在毛里塔尼亚住的酒店。那时我采访他已经好几天了，从未见过他如此兴奋。
She is stuck. She's so frustrated because she couldn't interrogate me. And she wants to interrogate me now, to have closure. I'm not giving her that closure.
她被卡住了。她非常沮丧，因为她没能审讯我。她现在想审讯我，以寻求了结。我不会给她那种了结。
She's dying to have answers.
她渴望得到答案。
She's dying to interrogate me, and she was kicked out. She was sent away. I am-- she was there not to check on my health.
她渴望审讯我，但我把她赶走了。她被打发走了。我……她在那儿根本不是为了检查我的健康。
She was there to put me behind bars for the rest of my life. I am not giving her the satisfaction. You know, I'm letting her die with frustration. That's my plan.
她是来把我终身监禁的。我不会给她那种满足感。你知道，我让她死于挫败感。这就是我的计划。
Your revenge.
你的复仇。
I mean, my sweet revenge, intellectual revenge. That was my plan.
我是说，我甜蜜的复仇，智力上的复仇。这就是我的计划。
Bastian Berbner. Coming up, Mohamedou talks to the interrogator who literally haunts his nightmares the most. That's in a minute with Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
巴斯蒂安·伯布纳。接下来，穆罕默杜将与那位在噩梦中一直困扰他的审讯员交谈。一分钟后回到芝加哥公共广播电台，继续我们的节目。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. If you're just tuning in, today on our program, we're listening to these very unusual conversations between Mohamedou Ould Slahi, a former Guantanamo detainee, and three of the Americans who were his captors at Guantanamo.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。如果你刚转过来，今天在我们的节目中，我们正在收听穆罕默杜·乌尔德·斯拉希，一位关塔那摩前囚犯与三名关塔那摩狱卒之间非常不寻常的对话。
In Mohamedou Ould Slahi's book, one of the most chilling sections is about an interrogator who we only knew as Mr. X. He shows up in the next part of our show. Act 2, Mr. X. Our reporter for this hour is Bastian Berbner. Here he is.
在穆罕默杜·乌尔德·斯拉希的书里，最令人不寒而栗的章节之一是关于一位我们只知道是“X先生”的审讯员。他出现在我们节目的下一部分。第二幕，X先生。我们这小时的记者是巴斯蒂安·伯布纳。这是他。
During the summer of 2003, Mohamedou was interrogated in three shifts by three interrogators, up to 18 hours a day. Mr. X was the guy who came at night.
2003年夏天，穆罕默杜被三名审讯员轮流审讯，每天长达18小时。X先生是那个晚上来的人。
Do you remember when you saw Mr. X for the last time?
你记得你最后一次见到X先生是什么时候吗？
I never saw Mr. X, so there is no seeing him the last time or the first time.
我从没见过X先生，所以不存在最后一次或第一次见到他。
What do you mean?
什么意思？
Like, he was always in his overall, and he had this mask that completely covered his face.
他总是穿着工作服，戴着那种完全遮住脸的面具。
Completely?
完全遮住？
Yeah, completely covered his face. You couldn't see anything.
是的，完全遮住。你什么都看不到。
Even his eyes?
连眼睛都看不见？
Everything. Everything. It's like a bag he would put on his head. Or I don't know whether he could see even through it. But I could see the shape of his body, you know, and--
什么都看不见。就像一个他会套在头上的袋子。我甚至不知道他能不能透过它看东西。但我能看到他身体的轮廓，你知道，而且——
Can you describe it?
你能描述一下吗？
Yeah, he was tall, skinny, muscular.
是的，他个子高，精瘦，肌肉发达。
Mr. X wore blue overalls, like a car mechanic. Black boots, black gloves, black ski mask, sunglasses. When he talked to Mohamedou, he called him by his prisoner number, 760.
X先生穿着蓝色工作服，像个汽车修理工。黑色靴子，黑色手套，黑色滑雪面罩，太阳镜。当他和穆罕默杜谈话时，他叫他的囚犯编号，760。
Night after night, he tried to break Mohamedou. He blasted heavy metal music and exposed him to strobe lights. He cranked up the AC until Mohamedou started shivering. He turned up the heat until he sweat through his clothes.
夜复一夜，他试图击垮穆罕默杜。他播放重金属音乐，让他暴露在频闪灯下。他调高空调直到穆罕默杜开始发抖。他调高暖气直到他汗水浸透衣服。
He made him stand with his wrists chained to a bolt on the floor, forcing him into a stooped position for hours, which was excruciating for Mohamedou. It was all part of the interrogation plan crafted specifically to break Mohamedou. Donald Rumsfeld signed off on it.
他强迫他手腕铐在地板上的螺栓上站着，逼成弯腰姿势数小时，这对穆罕默杜来说非常痛苦。这是专门为击垮穆罕默杜而制定的审讯计划的一部分。唐纳德·拉姆斯菲尔德批准了它。
The worst incident Mohamedou describes was a day in late August, 2003, when a few men dragged him out of the interrogation room, put blackout goggles on his eyes, earmuffs over his ears, and threw him into a Humvee. They drove him around and beat him. He was bleeding from his head.
穆罕默杜描述的最糟糕事件是2003年8月下旬的一天，几个男人把他从审讯室拖出来，给他戴上遮光护目镜，耳罩覆盖耳朵，扔进悍马车。他们开车带他到处转，并打他。他的头在流血。
They put him on a boat for a few hours. At one point, he heard people speaking in Arabic, as if he was going to be handed over to another country. What they had actually done was drive the boat around the Guantanamo Bay all day.
他们把他放在船上几个小时。有一度，他听到人们用阿拉伯语说话，好像他要被移交给另一个国家一样。他们实际上做的是整天开着船在关塔那摩湾转悠。
At the end, they put him in a cell built to maximize his isolation. No daylight, little sound, no objects of any sort. That's when Mohamedou broke.
最后，他们把他关进了一个为了最大化隔离而建的牢房。没有日光，几乎没有声音，没有任何物体。那时穆罕默杜崩溃了。
He started to produce all this information, so much that they got him a computer to type it all out. Mohamedou says, the stuff he told them, all of it was bullshit. In fact, when the military prosecutor building a case against him learned that Mohamedou was tortured, he dropped the case.
他开始制造所有这些信息，多到他们给了他一台电脑来打出来。穆罕默杜说，他告诉他们的东西，全是废话。实际上，当负责建立针对他的案子的军事检察官得知穆罕默杜遭受了酷刑时，他放弃了起诉。
Mohamedou remembers that it was Mr. X who beat him the worst during the mock rendition. For all those years since, he considered Mr. X his worst tormentor. Mr. X is the one who, 18 years later, still wakes him with nightmares.
穆罕默杜记得，在模拟引渡期间，X先生打他打得最狠。此后的所有岁月里，他都认为X先生是他最糟糕的折磨者。X先生是那位在18年后，依然在噩梦中惊醒他的人。
John searched for Mr. X for years. And then, one day, he got a tip about a Facebook profile. It had photos of a guy, extremely muscular, like a bodybuilder. John sent him messages.
约翰寻找X先生多年。然后，有一天，他得到了关于一个脸书账号的消息。那里面有照片，一个极其肌肉发达的家伙，像个健美运动员。约翰发了消息给他。
Two years later, he agreed to a meeting in a city hours away from where he lives. He looks a lot different now. He's still physically imposing, but the muscles are gone.
两年后，他同意在离他住处几个小时车程的城市见面。他现在看起来大不相同了。他依然身体强壮，但肌肉不见了。
He wears hipster glasses, and his beard is graying. And just to state the obvious, his name is not actually Mr. X. He let us film him for the documentary, but we agreed not to use his real name for the story.
他戴着文青眼镜，胡子花白。为了说明显而易见的事实，他的名字实际上不是X先生。他同意让我们为纪录片拍摄他，但我们同意不在报道中使用他的真名。
So who was Mr. X?
那么X先生是谁？
So I take it you're not literally saying, who is me, Mr. X. Who is Mr. X? Well, Mr. X was the thing that comes at night that you don't want to have to talk to. So the first thing I did was, well, I need to strip away my humanity. I need to not look like a normal human being. And I did that by covering up.
我想你不是在字面上问，“谁是我，X先生”。谁是X先生？好吧，X先生是那个晚上会出现，而你不想与之交谈的东西。所以我做的第一件事是，嗯，我需要剥去我的人性。我需要看起来不像一个正常的人类。我通过遮挡自己做到了这一点。
What other elements did it have to create Mr. X? What other stuff did you need?
创造X先生还需要什么其他要素？还需要什么东西？
Well, from a theatrical perspective, there was-- he had to be completely in control, and that was by design, to strip control from Slahi. Slahi liked to be in control. He'd try to take control of interrogations all the time. So one minute, I could be very rational, and then the next minute, I could be completely enraged at the slightest comment, possibly even an innocuous comment. It didn't even have to make sense.
嗯，从戏剧角度来看，必须……他必须完全处于控制之中，这是为了设计剥夺斯拉希的控制权。斯拉希喜欢保持控制。他总是试图控制审讯。所以这一分钟，我可以非常理智，下一分钟，我会因为哪怕最小的评论，甚至无意义的评论而完全暴怒。甚至不需要有任何意义。
Give me a general sense of what the dynamic between the two of you was.
给我一个关于你们之间动力的一般概念。
There was hardly any dynamic. He was the boss.
几乎没有任何动力。他是老板。
What do you mean?
什么意思？
He was the boss. He was deciding when I sit down, when I stand up, when I have a chair, when I write, when I don't write, when I go back to my room. He was calling all the shots. There was nothing. I was just an object in that relationship, and I just accepted my fate.
他是老板。他决定我什么时候坐下，什么时候站起，什么时候有椅子，什么时候写，什么时候不写，什么时候回房间。他掌握着所有决策。没有什么。在那段关系中我只是一个物体，我只是接受了我的命运。
When John asked Mr. X if he wanted to speak to Mohamedou again, he said no. It's a complicated thing for him. He told John about it in the car.
当约翰问X先生是否想再和穆罕默杜说话时，他说不。对他来说这是一件复杂的事。他在车里告诉约翰。
Yeah, why are you talking to us? I mean, like, you know, because other people didn't want to talk to us, you know. Why are you talking to us?
是啊，你为什么和我们说话？我是说，你知道，因为别人不想和我们说话，你知道。你为什么和我们说话？
Because it's the right thing to do. So one, I want to-- I don't want Mr. Slahi to have the sole voice of what occurred. But more importantly, when I was there, and we were told at one point that we were at this historical-- this historical point in American history, you know, that we were heroes and we were on the side of righteousness.
因为这是正确的事。所以第一，我想……我不希望斯拉希先生拥有关于发生什么的唯一声音。但更重要的是，我当时在那里，我们曾被告知我们处于这一历史性的……这一美国历史的历史时刻，你知道，我们是英雄，我们站在正义的一边。
But if you take the Slahi case alone, that's not what happened. We're not on the right side of history on this one. So I want to put out for the record that we made mistakes, in my opinion.
但如果你单看斯拉希案，那不是发生的。在这一件事上我们不在历史正确的一边。所以我想要把我们犯错记录在案，依我之见。
And people should never be treated that way. And that's created a lot of problems for me psychologically. And I told you before, I had, basically, a mental collapse over it.
而且人们永远不应该那样被对待。这在心理上给我造成了很多问题。我之前告诉过你，我因为这件事基本上精神崩溃了。
Unlike Sydney, who was an analyst, Mr. X was an interrogator. Guantanamo was his first time doing that job. He was in his mid-30s and part of an elite military unit at Guantanamo, called the Special Projects Team.
与身为分析师的悉尼不同，X先生是一名审讯员。关塔那摩是他第一次做那份工作。他30多岁，是关塔那摩一个精锐军事小组的成员，称为“特别项目小组”。
There were eight people in all-- interrogators and analysts. They only worked the most high-value detainees, the most important of whom at the time was Mohamedou Ould Slahi. The military thought he might have information that could lead to bin Laden or prevent the next big attack.
总共有八个人——审讯员和分析师。他们只处理最有价值的囚犯，其中当时最重要的是穆罕默杜·乌尔德·斯拉希。军方认为他可能拥有能引向本·拉登或阻止下一次大袭击的信息。
Mr. X's job was to make Mohamedou talk. And the idea was, you do that by being tough, really tough, using what they called enhanced techniques.
X先生的工作是让穆罕默杜开口。思路是，你通过强硬手段——非常强硬——使用他们所谓的“强化技术”来做到这一点。
Enhanced techniques were harsh interrogation techniques that today are outlawed, that today are illegal.
“强化技术”是严厉的审讯技术，今天已被法律禁止，今天是非法的。
So, torture.
所以，酷刑。
Some would be considered absolutely-- would be considered torture by today's standards, absolutely. Yes.
有些人会认为绝对……按照今天的标准会被认为是酷刑，绝对。是的。
And what about your standards?
那你的标准呢？
Yes. Yeah. Yeah, you got to understand, it's hard. It's hard to-- it's a hard thing to say.
是的。是啊。是啊，你得明白，这很难。很难……这是一个很难说出口的事。
Wait, what's hard?
等等，什么很难？
That I was involved in something that's torture, right? That somebody was psychologically tortured. Now, these things are still being debated today.
我参与了酷刑，对吧？有人被心理折磨了。现在，这些事情今天还在争论。
And so did you torture?
那你是否使用了酷刑？
Yeah. I mean, it's torture.
是的。我是说，这就是酷刑。
When Mr. X returned home after Guantanamo, he started to really think about what he had been part of. He began drinking, retreated from his wife and kids. He had obsessive thoughts about mutilating himself.
当X先生离开关塔那摩回到家后，他开始真正思考他参与过的事情。他开始酗酒，远离妻子和孩子。他有残害自己的强迫性思维。
A doctor diagnosed PTSD. For Mr. X, this was the start of a process of self-examination. There is hardly a day, he says, that he doesn't think about Mohamedou.
医生诊断为创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）。对X先生来说，这是自我审视过程的开始。他说，几乎没有一天他不想到穆罕默杜。
John tried to persuade Mr. X to talk to him. There was a film crew in Mauritania all set up in case he agreed. Mr. X was reluctant. He still thinks Mohamedou was a terrorist. And having read his book and a few interviews that Mohamedou had done, he got the sense that he's on a mission to rebrand himself from suspected terrorist to magnanimous forgiver.
约翰试图说服X先生和他谈谈。电影摄制组在毛里塔尼亚布置好了场地，以防他同意。X先生很犹豫。他依然认为穆罕默杜是个恐怖分子。读过他的书和穆罕默杜做过的几次采访后，他感觉他正肩负着将自己从嫌疑恐怖分子重塑为宽宏大量的原谅者的使命。
I think if I were to engage him in a conversation about this, that in a way, I would be feeding into his brand that he's making himself now. And I don't feel comfortable with that. I really don't.
我想如果我就此和他展开对话，某种程度上，我就是在为他正在建立的品牌添砖加瓦。我对此感觉不舒服。真的。
They're in his garage. Mr. X says he needs to think about it. He goes over to work with some pottery clay, something he's been doing as a kind of therapy.
他们在他的车库里。X先生说他需要考虑一下。他过去用陶土工作，这是他作为一种治疗方式一直在做的事情。
All right.
好吧。
A few minutes later, John tries again.
几分钟后，约翰再次尝试。
You're going to do some art and think about making the phone call?
你要做些艺术并考虑打那个电话吗？
[LAUGHS] Yeah, I just did the art. Can I have a second or what? (CHUCKLING) Gosh, John.
[笑] 是啊，我刚做完艺术。能给我一秒钟吗？（轻笑）天哪，约翰。
[JOHN CHUCKLES]
[约翰轻笑]
I'm just wondering.
我只是好奇。
[MR. X GROANS]
[X先生呻吟]
Why not? In for a penny, in for a pound, John, so--
为什么不呢？做了就做到底吧，约翰，所以——
OK. All right.
好的。好吧。
I'm trusting you on this.
这件事我信任你。
Yeah. Erin, could you come? Wait a second.
是啊。艾琳，你能过来吗？等一下。
You're gonna call him right now?
你现在就要给他打电话吗？
Yeah. Wait a second.
是啊。等一下。
Oh, my lord.
哦，老天。
The producers quickly set up a call on a laptop and hand it to Mr. X. Mohamedou is looking back at him from Mauritania, 17 years after they last met. He's seen photos of Mr. X before, but this is the first conversation they've had with each other where he isn't wearing a mask.
制片人迅速在笔记本电脑上设置了通话并交给X先生。穆罕默杜正在毛里塔尼亚看着他，那是他们最后一次见面17年之后。他之前见过X先生的照片，但这是他们第一次进行不戴面具的谈话。
Mr. Slahi. How are you?
斯拉希先生。你好吗？
How are you doing, sir?
你好吗，长官？
I'm not unwell. How about yourself?
我没病。你呢？
I'm doing very well.
我很好。
That's good.
那就好。
Thank you for asking.
谢谢你的问候。
Yes, sir. Well, it's interesting. I was exceptionally reluctant to make this call, because I have a lot of mixed feelings about the era and the things that happened. But I wanted to explain a couple of things to you.
是的，长官。嗯，很有趣。我异常犹豫要不要打这个电话，因为我对那个时代和发生的事情有非常复杂的感觉。但我想要向你解释几件事。
Mr. X starts talking and takes control of the conversation.
X先生开始说话并掌控了对话。
So first and foremost--
所以首先，最重要的是——
He doesn't stop for four minutes. And the thing he begins with isn't how the torture was wrong. It's about him, Mr. X, and how Mohamedou described him in his book. Mr. X says he wasn't the one who beat Mohamedou during the mock rendition, which, from my reporting, does seem to be true.
他四分钟没停。他开始说的不是酷刑怎么错误。而是关于他自己，X先生，以及穆罕默杜在书里是怎么描述他的。X先生说，模拟引渡期间打穆罕默杜的不是他，根据我的报道，这似乎是真的。
And I was shocked and just floored that you perceived that I was one of the people that entered the room and inflicted the physical abuse upon you. I'm not sure why you perceived that. It does bother me greatly that anyone, but especially you, would think that Mr. X would do that.
我很震惊，也很难过，你竟然认为我是进入房间对你实施身体虐待的人之一。我不确定你为什么会有那种感知。任何一个人，尤其是你，认为X先生会那样做，这让我感到非常困扰。
That's not Mr. X, and that's not me and who I really am. You see? So you were right to be surprised that Mr. X would have done something like that, because I didn't. I will tell you, another part that's difficult for me here, talking to you, is that I'm not convinced of your innocence.
那不是X先生，那不是我，不是真实的那个我。你明白吗？所以你感到惊讶是应该的，因为我没做过那种事。我要告诉你，在这里和你谈话对我来说困难的另一部分是，我不确信你的清白。
And I still believe, based on the information that I had received, that you are an enemy of the United States. But I will say that no one deserved the treatment that you received, that we were misguided. And what we did was absolutely, without question, wrong.
而且根据我收到的信息，我依然相信你是美国的敌人。但我会说，没有人应该受到你所受的那种待遇，我们被误导了。毫无疑问，我们所做的是绝对错误的。
So no one who is in-- no one in a-- no democratic society, based on the values of America as I understand, should have been arrested the way you were, brought to Guantanamo, treated the way you were, and kept as long as you were. That's all I can say. And I-- you know, I just-- I hope you have a good life, man.
所以没有人在……在一个民主社会，基于我所理解的美国价值观，没有任何人应该像你那样被逮捕，被带到关塔那摩，被那样对待，并且被关押那么久。我只能说这些。而且我……你知道，我只是……我希望你能过上好生活，伙计。
Did you want to respond at all, or--
你想要回应一下吗，或者——
I guess. So first of all, I have no reason to believe that you're lying to me. I have no reason to believe that. All I can say is that that's what I perceived, based on your voice I've been hearing for so many nights, so many late nights, with so much pain and suffering.
我想是的。首先，我没有理由相信你在对我撒谎。我没有理由相信这一点。我只能说，那是我根据在那么多深夜听到的你的声音所感知的，带着那么多的痛苦和折磨。
What happened happened, and I'm completely-- if you did it or you didn't do it, I'm just saying that I completely forgive you or anyone who inflicted pain. And that's wholeheartedly, because I want to forgive myself, and I want to live in peace with me. And--
发生的事情已经发生了，我完全……不管你做过还是没做过，我只是说，我完全原谅你或任何施加痛苦的人。那是全心全意的，因为我想原谅我自己，我想与自己和平共处。而且——
Yeah, I think everybody has to accept their actions and forgive themself. So I want to make sure it's also clear I'm not asking you for your forgiveness. I have to forgive myself. So--
是啊，我想每个人都必须接受自己的行为并原谅自己。所以我想要确保你也清楚，我不是在请求你的宽恕。我必须原谅我自己。所以——
That's OK.
没关系。
Yeah, and I knew you would know that. But in a strange way, I thought it was important for you to know that I know what happened to you. I know how it happened.
是啊，而且我知道你会明白的。但在某种奇怪的方式下，我觉得让你知道我知道发生在你身上的事情很重要。我知道它是怎么发生的。
It sounds exactly like how you describe it, except for the fact that it was me and these other people. I never did any of that stuff. So you can believe it or not. It's fine. But I acknowledge that it occurred.
听起来完全像你描述的那样，除了那是我和其他人。我从来没做过那种事。所以你信不信都行。没关系。但我承认它发生了。
So it's OK. Thank you very much for acknowledging it. As to the assertion that I'm-- maybe-- or I am the enemy of the United States, I can assure you, for better or worse, for what it's worth, that I've never been the enemy to your country.
所以没关系。非常感谢你承认它。至于断言我是……也许……或者我是美国的敌人，我可以向你保证，无论好坏，无论价值如何，我从来都不是你国家的敌人。
I've never hurt anyone of your country. And for that matter, I never hurt any person, ever, ever. And the facts of my case speak to that.
我从来没有伤害过你们国家的任何人。而且就此而言，我从未伤害过任何人，从来没有。我案子的事实说明了这一点。
Mr. X tells Mohamedou he believes he was released because the torture made his case impossible to prosecute, not because he was actually innocent.
X先生告诉穆罕默杜，他相信他被释放是因为酷刑使他的案子无法起诉，而不是因为他实际上是无辜的。
I just want to mention one thing to you. So if the United States tortures people, they don't release them, and they don't win cases because they were tortured. Case in point, KSM.
我想向你提一件事。所以如果美国折磨人，他们不会释放他们，也不会因为他们被折磨了就赢了案子。例子就是KSM。
KSM is Khalid Sheikh Mohammed, the man accused of being the mastermind behind 9/11. He was waterboarded 183 times in a secret prison, and then brought to Guantanamo, where he remains today.
KSM是哈立德·谢赫·穆罕默德，被指控为9/11幕后主使的人。他在秘密监狱里被水刑了183次，然后被带到关塔那摩，至今仍在那里。
And the people around him, they were heavily tortured, and they are still in prison. So it's not like the United States--
而他周围的人，他们遭受了严酷的折磨，他们仍被关在监狱里。所以这并不是说美国——
So let me do this, because I'm not going to get into the greater policy decisions that are made above me and above you. You know what I mean? I'm taking ownership of the things that I was involved in.
让我这么说吧，因为我不想进入那些高于我、高于你的宏观政策决定中。你明白我的意思吗？我正在承担我所参与事情的责任。
The way Mr. X interrupts Mohamedou here, he does that several times during the call. Whenever Mohamedou brings something up that Mr. X doesn't want to talk about, he cuts him off. It's a tactic he used during the interrogations at Guantanamo to keep Mohamedou on point, keep him talking about the things Mr. X wanted to hear.
X先生打断穆罕默杜的方式，在通话中发生了好几次。每当穆罕默杜提到X先生不想谈的事情时，他就会打断他。这是他在关塔那摩审讯期间使用的战术，目的是让穆罕默杜保持重点，谈论X先生想听的事情。
The call lasts about 19 minutes. Mr. X speaks for about 14 of them. He seemed like a different person than before the call, when he was polite and considerate. It was like a switch had flipped inside him. John tries to change the dynamic by bringing up something he and Mr. X had talked about.
通话持续了大约19分钟。X先生讲了大约14分钟。他看起来和通话前礼貌、体贴的态度完全不同。好像他内心的一个开关被翻转了。约翰试图通过提出他和X先生谈过的事情来改变动力。
If it's OK with you, I'm going to send him a picture.
如果你不介意，我要给他发一张照片。
John wants to send you the painting I did.
约翰想要给你展示我画的画。
I'd love to see his reaction.
我很想看到他的反应。
This is one of the paintings Mr. X made after he left the military. It was a portrait of Mohamedou as he remembers him the day when he was beaten. Mr. X destroyed the painting after he made it.
这是X先生离开军队后画的画之一。这是他记忆中穆罕默杜被打那天模样的肖像。X先生画完后销毁了那幅画。
He says it was too upsetting to look at. But he has a photo of it on his phone. John texts Mohamedou the photo while they talk.
他说看着它太令人难过了。但他手机上有它的照片。约翰在他们谈话时给穆罕默杜发了照片。
So is-- how are you living now? So are you married? Do you have kids?
那么……你现在过得怎么样？你结婚了吗？有孩子吗？
I'm not going to talk about my family. I'm not going to talk about my family, man. I'm not going to talk about my family or where I am or what I do or don't do. That's just how it is, pal.
我不会谈论我的家人。我不会谈论我的家人，伙计。我不会谈论我的家人或者我在哪里，或者我做什么或不做什么。事情就是这样，伙计。
Can you tell him that the painting--
你能告诉他那幅画——
He said he sent the painting to you. Did you receive it yet?
他说他把画发给你了。你收到了吗？
I have--
我还没——
An image-- it's on your WhatsApp.
一张图片——在你的WhatsApp上。
In the painting, Mohamedou is in bad shape. He's bleeding from his nose and lip. Underneath the blackout goggles, his eye is swollen and bloody. Mr. X said, in all his years, he had never seen anyone that terrified.
画中，穆罕默杜状况很差。鼻子和嘴唇在流血。在遮光护目镜下，他的眼睛红肿且带有血迹。X先生说，在他所有那些年里，他从未见过有人那么惊恐。
Ah, I see. Ah, wow. This detainee looks much better than the actual detainee.
啊，我看到了。啊，哇。这个囚犯看起来比真实的囚犯好多了。
[BOTH CHUCKLE]
[两人轻笑]
I don't think so. You didn't look very good that day, and that painting is not meant to make you-- it's to reflect what happened to you, so. If I had done the things, I wouldn't have painted that. [CHUCKLES] So.
我不这么认为。那天你看起来不太好，那幅画并不是为了让你……它是为了反映发生在你身上的事，所以。如果我做了那些事，我就不会画那个。[轻笑] 所以。
Anyway, I wish you good luck, man, wherever you are, whatever you do. And you know, that's all I can tell you. And I completely-- I completely-- like I say, I forgive you. I don't need you to ask for any forgiveness.
总之，祝你好运，伙计，无论你在哪，无论你做什么。你知道，我只能告诉你这些。我完全……我完全……就像我说的，我原谅你。不需要你请求任何宽恕。
I got you. That's a personal thing. I get it. Yeah.
我明白了。那是私人的事。我懂了。是啊。
Yes.
是的。
All right. Well, I look forward to seeing the movie when it comes out.
好了。嗯，我很期待电影上映时去看看。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Yup. I really don't have anything else to say.
是啊。我真的没什么别的要说了。
Bye!
再见！
Goodbye, Mr. Slahi.
再见，斯拉希先生。
Tschüss.
再见（德语）。
Tschüss. Close it? What am I doing? Yeah? Bye.
再见（德语）。关掉？我这是在做什么？是啊？再见。
Mr. X turns to John.
X先生转向约翰。
Are you happy?
你高兴吗？
Mr. X wasn't happy. The way he sees it, it's a big deal for a former interrogator to talk to a guy he thinks was a terrorist and admit the way they treated him was wrong. But Mohamedou didn't seem to care.
X先生不高兴。在他看来，一个前审讯员与一个他认为曾是恐怖分子的人谈话并承认对待他的方式是错误的，这是一件大事。但穆罕默杜似乎不在乎。
He just kept redirecting the conversation, the same way he had done in Guantanamo. So then he found himself cutting Mohamedou off. It was like being Mr. X again, the guy who he worked so hard to get away from for years.
他只是不断地改变谈话方向，就像他在关塔那摩所做的那样。结果他发现自己不得不打断穆罕默杜。这感觉就像再次变成了X先生，那个他多年来努力摆脱的人。
It wasn't a good feeling. It wasn't a good feeling at all. I mean, I was absolutely on the defensive, going into it. Like, I-- it is-- I can't even describe it to you.
这不是一种好的感觉。完全不是。我是说，进入通话时，我绝对处于防御状态。我……我甚至无法向你描述它。
I don't know about him, but I feel like we're inextricably locked in a dance, a macabre dance, perhaps to our dying day. In that moment, we weren't Slahi and who I am as a person. We really both kind of regressed. I really believe that's the case, and that's why I had the anger that was coming up. And I didn't like that.
我不知道他怎么想，但我觉得我们被不可分割地锁定在一场舞蹈中，一场恐怖的舞蹈，也许直到我们死亡的那一天。那一刻，我们不是斯拉希和我，而是作为一个人。我们真的都有点退化了。我真相信是这样，这就是我为什么感到愤怒的原因。我讨厌那样。
Do you fear that in this intellectual chess game, as you said, kind of who was winning the--
你是否担心在这个智力象棋游戏中，就像你说的，谁在赢得——
Oh, he won. He won the chess game. He has been masterful, first of all, for weathering what we subjected him to. The worst that we could throw at him. The worst.
哦，他赢了。他赢了这场象棋游戏。首先，他能够承受我们对他施加的一切，他是大师级的。我们能扔出的最糟糕的东西。最糟糕的。
To include stuff that should never happen, that is not allowed. He weathered 14 years or whatever, 15 years of confinement. He wrote a New York Times best-selling book, and most people, hearing his tale now, believe that he is completely innocent of anything that ever was alleged. And I don't think that that's accurate.
包括那些不该发生、不允许发生的事情。他忍受了14年或无论多少年，15年的监禁。他写了一本《纽约时报》畅销书，而现在听到他故事的多数人都相信他完全是无辜的，从未有过任何指控。我认为那是不准确的。
Take nothing away from him. I would do exactly the same things. I respect his intellect, his strength of will, his ability to parlay this into something else. Good for him, really. And I don't say this sarcastically. I mean it. Good for you, you know. And yeah, he won. You won that.
不要夺走他的一切。我会做完全相同的事。我尊重他的智力，他的意志力，他将此转化为其他东西的能力。为他感到高兴，真的。我不是讽刺。我是认真的。为你感到高兴，你知道。而且是啊，他赢了。你赢了那个。
But Mohamedou doesn't think he won. And he wasn't happy with how it went with Mr. X, how Mr. X dominated the call.
但穆罕默杜不觉得他赢了。他对与X先生的谈话方式、X先生如何支配通话感到不高兴。
I don't like monologues. Because when I want a monologue, I go to Friday prayers. And just the monologue that he kept on and on and on. And I was polite enough to listen to everything, but I don't want to listen to it anymore, you know. That's it.
我不喜欢独白。因为当我想听独白时，我就去参加周五的礼拜。他的独白一直继续着。而我表现得足够礼貌，听了这一切，但我不想再听下去了，你知道。就是这样。
How did it make you feel?
这让你感觉如何？
Weird. Weird. Because we say, we have a saying in my culture. Allah gave you one mouth and two ears. Do justice to your ears.
怪怪的。怪怪的。因为我们说，我们的文化里有一句话。安拉给了你一张嘴和两只耳朵。善待你的耳朵。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Would you be up for watching the conversation you had with him and kind of going into that a little bit?
你愿意观看你和他进行的对话，并稍微深入了解一下吗？
No, I don't want. It was a very bad conversation. I don't want to listen to it. You can listen to it. I'm not interested.
不，我不愿意。那是非常糟糕的谈话。我不想听它。你可以听。我没兴趣。
Mohamedou got his wish to have a conversation with his captors where he was a free man. He wanted that for all kinds of reasons-- forgiveness, revenge, to control his own story. With Scott and with Sydney, he found that very satisfying. But with Mr. X, what he hadn't counted on was how hard it would be for him, for them, to find a new way to talk to each other.
穆罕默杜实现了作为一个自由人与狱卒交谈的愿望。他想要那样有很多原因——宽恕、复仇、掌控自己的故事。和斯科特及悉尼在一起，他感到非常满足。但对X先生，他没料到对于他，对于他们，找到一种新的谈话方式有多难。
Bastian Berbner is a reporter for Die Zeit. If you speak German, the 12-part podcast series he made with John Goetz is called Slahi: 14 Years in Guantanamo. John Goetz's film, where we got the incredible audio that you heard today, is called In Search of Monsters.
巴斯蒂安·伯布纳是《时代周报》的记者。如果你懂德语，他和约翰·格茨制作的12集播客系列名为《斯拉希：在关塔那摩的14年》。约翰·格茨的电影，我们今天听到的不可思议的音频就来自其中，片名为《寻找怪物》。
It is now being shown in many European countries but has no American distributor yet. John is looking for a distributor. If you're somebody in the film distribution business, perhaps the streaming business, his contact information is on our website.
它现在正在许多欧洲国家放映，但还没有美国发行商。约翰正在寻找发行商。如果你是电影发行行业，也许是流媒体行业的人，他的联系信息在我们的网站上。
Darling, nothing's changed. I still think the same. You want to say. You've got some more to say. But I've heard it before. I've heard it before. All these things in time, these bad conversations on my mind.
亲爱的，什么都没变。我依然那么想。你想要说。你还有更多要说。但我以前听过了。我以前听过了。所有这些及时的事情，我脑中那些糟糕的谈话。
Well, our program was produced today by Dana Chivvis. People who put together today's show include Elna Baker, Susan Burton, Sean Cole, Aviva DeKornfeld, Damien Graef, Seth Lind, Stowe Nelson, Lina Misitzis, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Alix Spiegel, Laura Starecheski, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Chloee Weiner. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman, our senior editor is David Kestenbaum, our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
好了，我们的节目今天由达纳·奇维斯制作。参与今天节目制作的人员包括艾尔娜·贝克、苏珊·伯顿、肖恩·科尔、阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德、达米安·格拉夫、塞斯·林德、斯托·纳尔逊、莉娜·米西齐斯、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、劳拉·斯塔雷切斯基、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和克洛伊·温纳。我们的执行编辑是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼，我们的资深编辑是戴维·克斯滕鲍姆，我们的执行编辑是埃马努埃莱·贝里。
Special thanks today to Poul Erik Heilbuth, Ole Pflueger, the German public broadcaster, NDR, and Sarah Koenig. Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 750 episodes for absolutely free.
今天特别感谢保罗·埃里克·海尔布斯、奥尔·普弗卢格、德国公共广播公司NDR和萨拉·柯尼格。我们的网站ThisAmericanLife.org，在那里你可以免费流媒体播放我们超过750集的档案。
Plus there are videos, there is a list of favorite shows. There's tons of other stuff there. Again, ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
此外还有视频，最喜欢节目的列表。上面还有很多其他东西。再次重申，ThisAmericanLife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr Torey Malatia. When I walked in the studio earlier to record today's program, Torey was there, sitting right at this microphone. I was like, Torey, I need to get in there. He was all--
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。今天早些时候我走进演播室录制今天的节目时，托里就在那，正坐在麦克风前。我说，托里，我需要进去。他当时正……
Yeah, you will get your chance. But today, I'm running the show.
是啊，你会得到机会的。但今天，我是主角。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories on This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回到《美国生活》，带来更多故事。